what is up everybody it's 414 anime here
for anime up roll and today I'll be
breaking down just how strong series
protagonist Ichigo Kurosaki is from the
bleach series there is certainly a lot
to cover here so in this video we will
be breaking down ichigo's strength by
looking into his powers abilities fights
and more so make sure to stay tuned for
this one we have made a few bleach
videos on the channel now including a
video covering every Bankai in Bleach so
make sure to check that video out after
this one link to that is in the video
description now if you do enjoy these
bleach videos on the channel and you'd
like to see more you know what to do
smash that like button as it really does
help us out with that YouTube algorithm
if you haven't already make this the
video that you subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications you can also follow us on
Twitter and Instagram at anime or brawl
and now without further Ado let's jump
into It spoilers and all
Ichigo Kurosaki is 15 years old when we
are first introduced to him in the
series and is currently 29 years old he
stands at 181 centimeters or 5 foot 11
inches at present each go is the son of
ishin and masaki Kurosaki and the older
brother of both Karin and Yuzu he is now
married to orikime anoe and has a son of
his own called Kazooie Kurosaki
so we saw from the very beginning of the
series that Ichigo knew how to handle
himself in a fight and that lad did love
a good scrap to be honest he would often
get bullied for the color of his hair
which he said made him stand out as a
bit of a Target so he had no choice
other than to stand up for himself Not
only would Ichigo stand up for himself
but he would also stand up for others
that he felt were in need of protecting
Ichigo has always had a good sense of
doing the right thing and his very name
according to his father ishin means he
who protects now for all of ichigo's
incredible power and ability I feel like
his hand-to-hand combat goes under the
radar a little bit which is easily
overlooked as the series does put a
large amount of its focus on the soul
Reaper's zompoc toe or the special
abilities that these characters possess
we do know that Ichigo was trained in
martial arts from a very young age as he
attended the very same Dojo as tatsuki
Not only was he trained in martial arts
but he had many many skirmishes with his
dad is Sheen which were you know Plato's
viewers as comedic moments where asheem
would Ambush Ichigo in the morning or at
random moments and so on but now we look
at these little fights as ishin training
ichigo's instincts his intuition and
fighting abilities when it comes to
coordination and execution of his own
attacks we also saw very early on in the
series that Ichigo was already
physically strong himself prior to
receiving his soul Reaper Powers he kept
his body in very good shape and could
deliver very powerful punches and kicks
as well as being able to take down
multiple bullies on his own with no
effort on a very regular basis in the
very first episode or chapter we saw
each go crush a man's skull through
concrete with just a single kick in fact
I I remember Ichigo utilizing a lot of
kicks in the those very early episodes
or chapters
now Not only was Ichigo already
physically strong at this time but his
speed and reflexes were honed really
well and again this was before his soul
Reaper powers and him learning shampoo
each go was fast and agile he could
Dodge a bully's strike and instantly hit
them on the counter-attack so this
hand-to-hand combat experience and
training for me really does add to
ichigo's power yes it's not the big
flashy finishing move or anything but a
great example of when his hand-to-hand
combat was absolutely boss post
receiving his soul Reaper Powers has to
be in the soul Society after he had
achieved bunkai we saw Ichigo arrive at
the execution ground to save Rukia after
destroying the Sergio KU and making a
run for it with Rukia and renji in an
instant his physical strength and great
speed when it comes to hand-to-hand
combat was showcased when Ichigo took
down three lieutenants that were
dispatched after them that being Squad
4's isane Squad twos are maida and Squad
what one's sussak eBay after taking them
all down with single hits he then picked
his sambokto up to block an incoming
attack from biographia kuchki in
ichigo's blind spot which was very very
impressive Ichigo is of course a bit of
an all-rounder when it comes to who he
is and in such his powers and abilities
but I wanted to highlight that even
physical hand-to-hand combat plays a
part in what makes Ichigo such a strong
and powerful character and how it has
been fused into his style of combat we
have of course seen him use handhan
combat in some occasions throughout the
show but that moment in the soul Society
Arc had to be one of the key highlights
when mentioning this aspect of his
strength as it was for me yes such a big
moment I mean you look at that moment
and yes maybe it's a big moment for
other reasons but when you look at it
and break down what it is he did hear
then you can't argue that it is indeed a
contribution to the overall power that
each go possesses and something that in
aspects we will touch on again when it
comes to his powers and abilities as he
grows especially when it comes to his
soul Reaper powers
speaking of which let's look at how
ichio got said sorry for Powers now from
a very young age each girl could see
spirits now no age exactly as to when
this started but ichco has said that he
has been able to see and communicate
with them for as long as he can remember
now at this young age Ichigo did
struggle to tell the difference between
the living and the dead that he was
seeing one such occasion led to the
tragedy of his mother's passing one day
on the way home June 17th being the date
of this fateful day Ichigo only aged
nine at the time was with his mother
walking along the riverbank on their way
home the weather was awful as the rain
poured heavily it was here that Ichigo
saw a girl standing by the river the
girl looked as if she was about to jump
in so Ichigo ran out to try and save
this girl unfortunately said girl was
not alive and technically not even dead
for that matter but the law of the
hollow brand Fisher his mother masaki
tried her best to stop Ichigo but he did
not listen to her his one and only
priority was to protect Ichigo of course
failed to grab hold of the girl and fell
unconscious when he awoke he saw the
most tragic and life-changing thing
which was the body of his mother lying
on top of him covered in blood this
major event in ichigo's life completely
changed him and really began shaping him
as the man he would become so back to
his ability to see spirits many people
would see Ichigo in the strangest of
places seemingly talking to himself but
he was in fact talking to the spirits of
the deceased people would speak about it
and the rumors were that Ichigo could
see ghosts little did they know that
this was of course true however when
tusky questioned him on this he straight
out denied being able to see them for
Ichigo he wanted to keep this to himself
especially as it was this ability to see
the spirit of the Dead that was an
important part in the events that led to
his mother masaki's death so this leads
us to his first encounter with Rukia
kuchki when Ichigo first met her she
appeared in his bedroom and he thought
that she was a burglar Ichigo quickly
realized however that he was the only
one able to see this woman so he simply
accepted the fact that she was just
another ghost of course this was pretty
standard practice for Ichigo at this
point and was just another normal
everyday thing Rukia explained to Ichigo
that she was a soul Reaper and what a
soul Reaper was but Ichigo refused to
believe it and was rude to her in you
know typical Ichigo fashion which led to
Rukia binding him with keto it is of
course at that moment that a hollow
attacks the house and we get to see
another display of something that isn't
necessarily a power but something that
Ichigo possesses that lends to his
overall strength that being his will
Egypt goes well combined with his
burning need to protect allows him to
overcome and defeat obstacles that any
normal person cannot it allows him to
break barriers and push the boundaries
of his own abilities at their current
state at that time this of course excels
his growth and Taps into that untouched
potential that he of course has and I
mean yet you can really argue that this
is a classic Shonen trait but let us not
forget that Ichigo is a protagonist of
one of the big three Shonen Series so
you really can't argue with him having
this as a part of his personality or
powers and villages
both now this will power and the need to
protect kicks in here as he hears the
screams of his younger sisters Karin and
yuzuru both who are pleading for help
this fires eager up and his
determination to get out there and save
them allows him to break free of
rookia's Keto spell and he rushes to
stop the hollow this was of course the
first time Ichigo ever saw a hollow
kinda in in this form anyway but he was
shocked and surprised by just how
monstrous it looked nonetheless he dove
in to help save yuzuru who was being
held captive Rukia is also involved in
the fight as a soul Reaper naturally
however Ichigo acts recklessly which
again is another trait that is both a
strength and weakness when it comes to
each girl's overall power in this case
it is a very strong weakness as rookie
had to Shield him with her own body
which leaves her badly injured now in
this most dire of situation this is the
first time rookie sees the fiery
determination in ichigo's eyes to
protect inspired by this and in this
terrible situation Rukia offers to turn
Ichigo into a soul Reaper temporarily so
that he can save them all from the foe
at hand
she pierces his chest with her zompoc
toe transferring half of her own power
to him which allows each go to take on
the form of a soul Reaper and make short
work of the hollow now this may be
jumping way into the future of the
series here but there are definitely
moments sprinkled in the early stages of
the story and in the soul society that
are a nod or foreshadowing to ichigo's
Powers abilities and I guess identity
for that matter that we would have 100
overlooked or ignored when we first saw
or read the series
the first being this instance right here
where Rukia gives Ichigo half of her
powers so each go actually has the
ability to absorb reishi which is an
ability that the Quincy possess Quincy's
gained their power by absorbing the
ratio around them each Go's mother was a
Quincy herself thus Ichigo himself is
half Quincy meaning that he has his own
set of Quincy Powers including this one
right here so in this instance Rukia
intended to unstate it to only give
Ichigo half of her power but because of
this ability Ichigo unintentionally took
all of it so now a substitute Soul
Reaper ichiko dons the soul Reaper
attire and zompoc toe this sumpok toe is
similar to that of rukia's however it is
much much larger in size this size is
all down to the fact that at this time
Ichigo couldn't control the insane
amount of spirit Power that he possessed
and as such the this blade in particular
was pretty weak since very little of his
own spirit Power was used to create it
to elaborate here the zonpokto is a
representation and extension I guess you
could say of its wielder and the best
way to look at this sword is that it is
more representation of the stolen Spirit
energy of rookies than his own power
nonetheless it did allow Ichigo to get
the job done against the Lesser Hollows
that he was taking down around karakura
town now ichigo's biggest test in this
time was against the menos Grande that
was summoned in his face off with ulio
uriu had of course challenged Ichigo to
see who could finish off the most
Hollows by using a bait that Drew more
in now in this battle against the Manos
we got another snippet orb foreshadowing
of each ghost Quincy abilities Ichigo
again displayed his ability to absorb
reishi by taking in the menos's shadow
and then fire it bright back at it this
attack of course injures the Manos
enough to retreat and Ichigo claims the
victory here it was also during this
battle that uriu takes note of each
ghost overwhelming spirit Power he saw
that ichigo's spiritual pressure
continued to rise as he took the Saro
despite Ichigo himself saying that he
was already omitting his full power
impressive as this feat was you know let
us not forget that Meadows Grande are
considered Captain leveled Hollows
Ichigo was 100 not at that level at the
time remember The Meadows wasn't
defeated it simply retreated through an
injury I'm sure it wasn't expecting
Ichigo not being at that level of course
is backed up when he came face to face
with his first lieutenant and Captain
ranked Soul Reapers in renjiyabari and
biakyakuchiki the two who had come to
the world of the living to retrieve
Rukia this is a very important encounter
and we see a couple of things here the
first being ichigo's severe lack of both
knowledge and I guess you can argue
experience at this point especially
compared to the two powerhouses that
were standing before him Ichigo learns
of the bond a soul Reaper has with its
zombok toe in terms of knowing its name
and the fact that the zompoc toe has
released stages the released stages he
of course got first-hand experience from
in the form of renji's sheikai we did
get to see ichigo's Spirit pressure
dramatically increase so much so that he
managed to both injure and overwhelm
renji however this is when bjokia steps
in literally you know with his flash
step Bianchi are not only Cuts clean
through ichigo's sword but he also
performed one of his favorite and most
devastating techniques this technique
being called senka or Flash Blossom when
translated here he moves at his
opponent's back directly attacking and
sealing their sequetsu and hakusui this
is done in two very rapid and
devastating strikes which cuts off their
spiritual energy flow biakya senka
completely devastates each ago leaving
him on death's door but we do get to see
another of each ghost powers that power
being sheer determination and the will
to just never give in biokia is talking
to Rukia as Ichigo grabs his leg and
tells him not to talk about him as if he
was dead the Akia tells him to let go
and Ichigo commands biakya to look at
him when he is talking to him small
moment I guess but a big one for me at
the same time as this really sums up
ichigo's personality in these crunch
moments to be strong you know you can't
really just rely on power alone but it's
also the mindset to see it through
however this is still a defeat Ichigo is
later saved by urahara and undergoes
training to you know one restore his
lost soul Reaper powers and to prepare
himself for the soul Society where they
plan to save and rescue Rukia kuchiki
now at this time the important thing to
note here is that Ichigo had little to
no train training at all at this point
he was pretty much thrown into the job
and was learning as he went it was
techniques such as you know the soul
ribbons for example a simple technique
but one he had to pick up from from
people like uriu who of course isn't a
soul Reaper himself so if you look back
at this time and look at what he had
accomplished with you know such little
knowledge and training it's it's a very
clear nod to the fact that Ichigo is a
very quick learner and also one who has
very rapid growth but rapid growth is
something we will touch on in just a sec
so on to urahara's training Ichigo
underwent a few tests the first was to
get used to his soul form and regain his
soul Reaper powers that byakia had taken
from him in the first test he had to
learn how to move better in his soul
body better than that of his own body
and to do this he had to successfully
Dodge uru's attacks and then go on to
counter this test he of course passed
recovering his Spirit energy but the
next one was very important and also
very very dangerous so ichigo's Soul
chain or chain of Fate is cut and it
begins to corrode urahara tells him that
when the chain reaches his chest Ichigo
will become a hollow himself and thus
will have to be exterminated however he
can avoid this fate if he manages to
become a soul Reaper instead
Ichigo is then thrown into what urahara
calls the shattered shaft he is then
Bound by a keto spell and has to escape
the deep shaft before his chain
completely dissolves urahara also throws
in the fact that there is gas at the
bottom of this shaft that excels the
corrosion process and the Ichigo has 72
hours at most to complete this task of
course after a few failed attempts and a
whole lot of pain the chain does reach
his chest to which a large hole opens
and a Hollow Mask begins to form on his
face it is here that Ichigo blacks out
and awakens inside his own Consciousness
his inner world of course if you will it
is here that he meets a man standing on
a building who Reveals His Name to each
go however Ichigo cannot hear it the man
also reveals to Ichigo that byakya had
destroyed the powers that were given to
him by Rukia kuchiki however he does
have his own soul Reaper powers and that
now is the time time for him to find
them the buildings in his inner world
begin to crumble away and many boxes
appear with one of them containing his
soul Reaper Powers Ichigo must choose
the right one or is game over he wanders
to himself in a panic how he will manage
to pick the right one before remembering
the Red Ribbon lesson that he had
learned from who to you he follows the
Red Ribbon to a box that reveals the
hilt of his zompoc toe and he pulls it
from the box back in the real world
Smoke Clears and Ichigo is revealed to
have made it through the test wearing
Soul Reaper cloves however he does have
a Hollow Mask we get to see a real
badass moment here where Ichigo uses the
hilt of his zampark toe to smash the
Hollow Mask he is wearing revealing that
he had indeed passed the test this of
course moves us on to the third test
which is to knock off urahara's hat with
his zompoc toe in a five minute time
limit orahara unleashes his shikai
benahime while ijigo still wields the
stub of his zompoc toe urahara
completely overwhelms Ichigo and even
cuts the stub of his blade further until
only the hilt remains Ichigo begins to
panic here thinking that he can't fight
with just a hilt and if he does urahara
will most certainly kill him he runs
away until the man from his inner world
is stunning before him which halts
Ichigo in his tracks the man asks Ichigo
why he is is running and also Reveals
His Name to him again this time Ichigo
hears the name
zongetsu each go turns to face urihara
and calls out zongetsu's name which
activates his shikai revealing its new
form Ichigo tells urahara he may not be
able to hold back before swinging a
large energy blast straighter orahara
who manages to pull up his bloodmess
shield just in the nick of time
urihara's hat is blown clean off his
head but he states that he would have
lost an arm if he didn't get the shield
up in time and thus Ichigo completes the
third test so this is a good time to
talk about ichiko shikai here the
appearance of his zompoc toe is like
that of a huge kyber knife that Hilt has
a long cloth wrapped around it the blade
is black with a silver Edge and just as
tall as each go is now the cloth wrapped
around it is also said to react to
ichigo's Will and that it can change in
length this cloth can also be used to
swing the blade around a technique that
he doesn't learn until later when he
encounters his hollow self in his inner
world in the battle against Captain
kempachi Zaraki the blade is also super
wide just as it is tall to which each go
has used his zompoc toe as a sort of
shield in some occasions to block
incoming enemy attacks now Ichigo
zompokto is a full-time released form
due to the huge amount of spirit energy
that Ichigo possesses it is so vast that
he can't control the zombok toe into its
sealed state
right so we are moving on to the soul
Society here this is an arc where we see
major growth in ichigo's powers and
abilities from the very beginning we get
to see just how much of an improvement
he has made in his short training
sessions with urahara when he faced off
against the giant gatekeeper jadambo a
foe who he easily defeats we see in this
battle that his soul Reaper powers are a
lot more refined as are all of his other
attributes we talked at the start of the
video about ichigo's physical strength
being impressive prior to him gaining
his soul Reaper Powers but when he is in
his soul Reaper form this physical
strength is far more enhanced and with
his body toned we saw him easily stop
jadambo's ax before completely
destroying them with just a single blow
his already impressive punches and kicks
are also significantly boosted in their
strength allowing Ichigo to kick down
concrete walls with absolute ease along
with this his endurance and durability
are noticeably enhanced as Ichigo has
been seen to continue fighting to an
effective manner even after sustaining
multiple injuries that would completely
take out a normal person Rukia herself
had stated that a soul Reaper's life
force is tied to their spiritual
pressure and as we know Ichigo certainly
has a lot of that going on so with that
information we know that not only can he
withstand attacks that would kill a
human but also attacks that would
immobilize that of a normal Soul reaper
now his first real test upon getting
into the cerate was the then third seat
of the 11th division ikaku madarame
their fight was a really awesome one to
watch now two ferocious Fighters going
at it against one another with a level
of respect for each of the fighters tied
with Ian what this fight did showcase
was ichigo's intellect Ichigo is very
headstrong and his emotions are
ultimately the fuel behind his power for
the vast majority we have known him to
be Reckless overconfident and someone
that can just rush straight into things
but in this battle we saw his analytical
and deductive side as he studied both
ikaku's fighting style and his zompoc
toe combining his calm deductive
knowledge with his own brute strength
Ichigo was able to counter and beat
akaku beat akaku in a battle that really
did showcase how far Ichigo had come in
such a short time as is the theme of the
Soul Society Ark this fight also gave us
a good look at ichigo's swordsmanship
his fighting style is heavily dependent
on the sword though he will throw in his
physicality too he mainly wields his
zompoc toe in his right hand or will
take up a stance where he has both hands
on the hill of his blade but he has also
been seen on some occasions to wield his
zampokto in his left hand this tells us
that he is somewhat ambidextrous which
is an invaluable trait in battle when it
comes to adjusting your own battle
strategy to combat your opponent mid
battle each ago though with training
under his belt still lacks in the
experience and training that those in
the soul Society have and still has a
lot to learn as he goes but his style
really has developed through combat
experience rather than that of formal
training the stronger the opponent the
better Ichigo gets now I've always
likened Ichigo to the Saiyans in Dragon
Ball where they gain way more experience
through combat than in training and that
they also get significantly stronger
after suffering a defeat Ichigo is very
much the same here he tends to learn the
most important lessons when he is on the
back foot or in the aftermath of a
defeat as in these moments where each go
really undergoes a level up and with
each and every fight he becomes much
more powerful himself now the further
through the cerate he went the more
attention and interest he was gaining
from the other Soul Reapers of course
most noticeably the captain of the 11th
division who is desperately hunting down
each go like a dog but there was an
opponent Ichigo faced before him who
indeed proved to be his ultimate test at
this point which was division six
Lieutenant renji abarai this fight was a
true test of how far each go had come
not only because renji was a lieutenant
level but also because of the past
exchange that the two had had however
renji is a completely different beast in
this fight as he reveals that when in
the world of the living lieutenants and
captains have their powers capped but
here in the soul Society man anything
goes especially during these wartime
Like rules they had going on renji
proves to be more than a challenge for
Ichigo at this point as he injures
Ichigo greatly with his shikai sabimaru
now as I previously mentioned When
comparing Ichigo to the Saiyans in
Dragon Ball Ichigo gets stronger and
stronger during the fight and we see the
Pinnacle of his training with urahara on
full show here that being ichigo's
resolve Ichigo completely destroys is
renji with a very powerful getsouger 10
show attack giving our boy a huge win in
the arc at this point getsuga 10 show is
without a doubt one of the most famous
attacks in the world of anime and of
course ichigo's signature attack
guessouka 10 show is translated as
meaning Moon Fang Heaven piercer or
piercer of Heaven in the anime what it
is is a slash of condensed spiritual
energy that is fired at his opponent in
the shape of a crescent moon that
strikes his opponent with such
devastating Force dealing a lot of
damage to them Ichigo was actually using
this technique without knowing its name
for a while such as in the fight with
renji but later learns the name and
Masters the technique during his Bankai
training zongetsu stated that by knowing
the name of a technique it will
significantly increase its power and
Effectiveness now as the show progresses
we do learn more about the getsuga 10
show that I will cover as we move along
and we have seen it grow in its power as
well as you know in the way that Ichigo
uses it but it's just one of those anime
attacks that gets you hyped when you
hear the name that's for sure right the
next big moment for Ichigo comes in his
battle against kempachi a battle so
ferocious with a lot of improvement from
ijigo on show and to this day one of the
best fights in all of bleach in my
opinion anyway let me know in the
comments if you think the same so
initially we see a completely different
side to Ichigo in this fight as he is
struck and Frozen by a sense of complete
fear campachi is an absolute brute force
and has such an intense and ultimately
horrifying Force about him that is you
know it's no surprise that Ichigo feels
this way capachi is easily one of the
worst captains to come up against as
your first Kenpachi toyed with Ichigo
allowing him a free strike which
ichigo's blade simply hit campachi but
left Ichigo as the one who was bleeding
Kenpachi was utterly disappointed with
each go as he wanted a worthy opponent
to fight against but Ichigo was proving
to be very far from that struggling to
cook kempachi Ichigo was left with a
very fatal injury as kempachi walked
away from the fight only for zengetsu to
come to ichigo's Aid in more ways than
one zongetsu pulled Ichigo into his
inner world and was able to stop the
bleeding from the womb that Ichigo had
just suffered but only for a short
period of time this is all because the
old man is the representation of
ichigo's Quincy powers and this ability
is from that branch of powers he has
it's also another reason as to why
Ichigo can withstand and take on a lot
of damage anyway the other way he aided
Ichigo here was by repairing his resolve
but first he had to prove to zongetsu
that he was worthy of wielding him in
order for each girl to prove this he was
tasked with taking the zongetsu blade
back in a fight with his inner Hollow
using a nameless normal Katana Ichigo
succeeds in doing this but learns some
important lessons such as the fact that
Ichigo had always thought about himself
in battle rather than drawing out the
power of zongetsu to Aid him and fight
together fighting together with your
zomboto of course being you know the
main theme of Ichigo and kompachi's
battle kapachi relies solely on himself
and doesn't know the name of his zompoc
toe whereas Ichigo fights together with
zangetsu in order to draw upon his power
and the two fighters won Ichigo also
learns about how he can use the cloth of
his own Poco to swing his weapon
something he had never considered
himself but was shown just how
devastating attack it can be by the
hollow Ichigo now worthy to wield him
Ichigo awakens and the fight with
kimpachi resumes as both Fighters go all
out against each other kempaji unleashes
his full power by removing his eye patch
and Ichigo and zangetsu worked together
to bring out the their maximum at this
time which technically does end in a
draw here however Kenpachi gifts the win
to Ichigo this was such an amazing and
important fight for Ichigo as this
unlocks so much more of his potential by
learning to work together with his unbox
toe rather than simply using it as a
tool to fight now after this fight each
go is partially healed by yorichi before
Ichigo rushes after ganju and hanataro's
aide who are currently being confronted
by none other than biakya kuchki Ichigo
of course makes the classic Shonen
protagonist entrance which shocks
Captain Joe shuro ukitake who is with
byakya here he starts to state that this
man is someone of Captain levels which
byakia quickly shuts him down yes Ichigo
has gained Incredible strength here
especially after the kempachi fight but
he is certainly not Captain level just
yet I feel ukitake was thrown off by
ichigo's Insane Spirit pressure and
spiritual power as well as the fact that
his soul Reaper Powers come from his
father's side as Sheen Kurosaki you know
was a former captain of the 10th
division Spirit energy ukitaki probably
recognized straight away as would a few
of the other captains is of course been
mentioned a few times throughout the
video and it certainly won't be the last
but what is a huge factor in ichigo's
overall power is his very vast spiritual
power his spirit Power has been
described as almost immeasurable and
well beyond that of a normal Soul Reaper
it has even been described as feeling
heavy something the average Soul Reapers
does not give off which was the main
thing that threw renji off about Ichigo
when they first met giving each go that
opening that he needed so yeah he gives
off the level of spiritual pressure a
captain would have but his power did not
match that level at all just yet the
problem at hand for Ichigo is of course
control over the spirit energy and the
lack of training when it comes to being
able to handle it events in the story at
this point have just happened so fast
and ichko has just been thrust straight
into the action the problem he also has
here is that he has way more spiritual
power than his body can handle so it is
constantly rushing out of him which
would make him awful at stealth missions
but that's never been ichigo's style
thankfully this lack of training that
had been mentioned will eventually cease
as he does learn to control his Spirit
energy later on down the road to do
things such as boost his own strength
you know to use it as a barrier
defensively and so on but back to each
go confronting biakya here this is a
very evident Improvement of him you know
from their first meeting which does
catch biokya off guard but not enough to
worry him if this fight were to continue
each go would most definitely have lost
but luckily yorichi showed up just in
time to stop the fight knowing he is not
ready to take on an enemy of bioku's
power she rushes him away to undergo
Bankai training and tells byakia that
she will make each ghost stronger than
he is in only three days
each go is taken to an underground and
unknown to the sole Society location
where he can undergo said bonka training
now achieving bonkai is no easy feat it
is something that not just anyone can
achieve it usually takes to one of
Captain level quality or above with
training of a hundred years or more to
achieve the Bankai release alone and
then a further 10 years of training to
perfect it so how is Ichigo going to do
it in just three days well luckily key
skate or a horror had come up with an
invention called the 10 sheetai
translated as meaning Divine transfer
body this forces the physical
manifestation of the zompokto spirit
however this manifestation will only
last for three days before it reverts
back into the doll from where it was
initially spawned without this method it
would have been next to impossible to
achieve Bankai luckily Ichigo managed to
achieve Bankai in only two and a half
days which was actually quicker than
urahara who had used the same technique
to achieve Bankai himself in the three
days not only did Ichigo achieve Bankai
but he also improved a lot in all of his
other fighting aspects this is all due
to ichigo's Advanced growth now ishko's
Advanced growth is arguably his most
powerful ability as stated by both
urahara and Eisen himself Ichigo has the
ability to get the basic gist of a very
Advanced technique in a matter of days
that would usually take years for even
the most gifted of Soul Reapers in the
sole Society this is how he has been
able to get as far as he has without any
training Ichigo tends to grasp an
ability very quickly through sheer
Instinct his ability to achieve Bankai
in only two and a half days is a very
perfect example of this yes he had the
10 shintai but it is a very dangerous
way of achieving Bankai and he still had
to do it within that three-day time
limit so let's talk about ichiko's
bonkai ichko's Bankai is called tenza
zanketsu which is translated to mean
Heaven chain slaying moon with the
release of his bonkai ichigo's sword
shrinks down to a pure black daito which
is a Japanese long sword with its cross
guard being four prongs that form the
shape of the Manji which is the kanji
for ban this means full which in the
instance of Bankai is full release the
cloth that was once part of his shikai
is also replaced with that of a black
chain now his onpakto is said to be
completely out of the ordinary when it
comes to his bonkai as a normal zompoc
toes bunkai will either summon a huge
monster or produce a certain effect
ichigo's sword is also incredibly strong
in its bonkite form as it can cut
through nearly anything and also
withstand the strongest tags we must
also mention that ichigo's robes are
also replaced with a very Sleek looking
long-sleeve black cloak with a red
lining and ripped ends similar to that
of zombiesu's looks now this cloak is
actually a part of his bunkai as it is
made of his spiritual energy and is a
representation of just how much
remaining strength and power that he has
left in terms of his power and abilities
tenza zangetsu is a huge power-up when
it comes to ichigo's strength and
spiritual power that is used for heavy
melee combat as well as this his Bankai
seriously beefs up his gutsuga 10 show
which is a black and red version in his
Bankai this brings us to an interesting
thing about his getsuga tent show so the
getsuga 10 show we have seen Ichigo use
are interesting and they tie into the
powers that he has the blue or white
gets Suga ten show Taps into each ghost
Quincy Powers as zongetsu absorbs
ichigo's own spiritual power firing that
at his opponent in a condensed State
this works in the exact same way that a
Quincy's bow and arrow works now the red
or black gets Suga tensho is that of his
soul Reaper and Hollow powers in his
eventual fight with byakya his inner
Hollow takes over and this is where he
learns this version of the getsue 10
show rather than the Quincy version that
absorbs ichigo's spiritual power and
shoots the Shinigami and Hollow version
is performed when the two work together
to create the blast from both of their
powers rather than through absorption so
back to ichigo's bonkai his Bankai
allows him to perform hyper-speed combat
where he can take the power of His
Bankai and compress it into a smaller
form which allows him to fight at insane
speeds increasing his shunpo ability to
the point where his movements create
dozens of after images of himself the
compression of his bunkai's power also
extends the duration in which he can use
it as it doesn't expel as much spiritual
power as a normal bunkai this combined
with just how much spiritual power he
has means that he can fight in his
bunkai form for a very long time we're
jumping of course into the future a bit
here but from his fight final encounter
with green jowl all the way up until
eisen's defeat Ichigo maintained his
Bankai for the whole of that time period
which was three months there is a little
more to ichigo's Bankai well a lot more
actually but this is what we got for the
vast part of the story until later so
Ichigo arrives at rukia's execution
again in a very epic Shonen protagonist
Manner and here has an awesome moment
that highlights just how far his skill
in handling his spiritual power has
progressed in those three days Ichigo
managed to stop and hold back the
sogyoku bird that was going to execute
Rukia the sogioku bird being a whole
bird with the destructive power
equivalent to that of one million zompoc
toe combined and you know our boy
managed to hold it off with his
spiritual power big boy play Big Boy
play right there this of course moves us
into one of the greatest fights in all
of anime which is his Showdown with
biakya kuchki this fight is incredible
and really has it all Ichigo manages to
back biokya into a position where he has
to use his Bankai against him but each
go manages to keep up with it by just
using his Sheik eye biokya does manage
to get Ichigo to use his tensors on
Getsu which is the first time we got to
see it and man was that super epic so
with his bonkai released Ichigo is able
to completely outmaneuver bianchias
Bankai until he eventually counters with
his senky technique as the battle goes
on Ichigo starts to weaken which does
give Bianca the opening he needs so as
Ichigo is about to receive the final
Blow from bjokia ichigo's inner Hollow
takes over and completely overwhelms
bjokia this Display of Power was brutal
and very very intense the inner Hollow
was bloodthirsty and ready to do
whatever it wanted and despite being
able to get the win in this state Ichigo
manages to regain control as this is not
how he wants this to go down of course
this is not the way the Ichigo does
things now again in full control Ichigo
and biochia take up one final stance one
final clash between these two
powerhouses Ichigo comes out as the
Victor here but barely biokyo is
certainly no joke and it took everything
to come out on top but still was a huge
moment for Ichigo and his progression he
even earned respect from bjokia a man
who had been nothing more than
cold-hearted for as long as we knew him
but of course we find out his reasonings
the next area of focus when it comes to
ichigo's power has to be that of his
holification we saw glimpses of his
Hollow Mask throughout the soul society
and of course the Takeover in his battle
with bianchia when we move on to the
aranca arc the main focus is on that of
his holification and how he struggles to
control his inner Hollow after failed
battles most noticeably against the
Espada green jowl each goes confidence
in himself and his ability to protect
others is severely damaged he goes into
a really depressed state but he knows
there is a solution in those said
battles Ichigo had managed to get the
upper hand though only temporarily and
this was through the power of his inner
Hollow taking over him in order for each
girl to defeat these new threats to
protect the ones he holds closest to him
and to get stronger each go needed to be
able to control his inner Hollow and
gain access to its powers to do this he
went to the Wizards who are all able to
control the power of their own
holification and thus his training began
ichigo's inner Hollow is seriously no
joke and he nearly killed hiori when she
drew the inner hollow out of him Ichigo
was luckily stopped but told that he
needed to force his inner Hollow into
the very core of his soul after some
brief training Ichigo is sent into his
inner world to confront his inner Hollow
and subdue it this is no easy task as
the other visors had to control ichigo's
body in the real world while he was in
there that was rampaging and was truly a
devastating sight to behold meanwhile in
his inner World Ichigo was having a
terrible time against his inner Hollow
instead of being able to do damage to
his hollow he ended up getting stabbed
by it during this confrontation Ichigo
learned that he lacked any fighting
spirit and could only fight if he had a
reason to do so upon realizing this it
got him out of his own head out of the
slump he was in and he managed to to
subdue his inner Hollow and complete the
task he had set out complete following
this his training was solely focused on
increasing the time that he could stay
in his hollow Mast form which leads us
to a good point in the video to talk
about the qualification powers that each
go has so ichco's Hollow mask was
originally a sign that his inner Hollow
had taken over him until he had
completed his training in subduing his
hollow The Mask now simply means that he
is using the powers of his holification
in order for Ichigo to activate the
power of His holification he places his
hand over his face and concentrates his
spiritual power to manifest and summon
the mask over his face when the mask is
done his eyes become black with yellow
pupils and his voice has a slight Hollow
Echo to it this voice sounds really
haunting and I I loved that I think it
sounded awesome now in terms of the
mask's appearance ichigo's Hollow mask
is that of a gnarly looking skull that
is white in color and originally had
three red stripes on its left side as he
learned to control the power and stay in
the form for longer more stripes began
to appear on that same left side the
thickness of the lines had also
increased after he managed to subdue his
inner Hollow by the time he fought green
jowl for the third and final time his
mask had a total of 10 Stripes later in
his fight with ukiora ichiko's mask
changed again where he had two vertical
thick red stripes on either side of the
Mask now when Ichigo Taps into his
holification his hollow Powers
significantly boost all of his
shittigami powers ichigo's strength
speed and durability stats all Skyrocket
as we mainly see against greenjao he was
strong enough to overpower greenja's
Sparta class Cerro Ichigo was fast
enough to completely overwhelm him and
his durability was showcased when
greenjao threw Ichigo through multiple
buildings on Rubble only for each Ghost
come out of that on her harmed each
ghost combat style while in his
holification form is a lot more ruthless
it's full-on and focuses on completely
overwhelming his enemy his instincts are
also heightened however his recklessness
is also when holified each go completely
disregards any injuries or wounds that
he has suffered in the battle and goes
on to attack it's a lot less strategic
when in this form and more about getting
the job done quickly the power of His
gutsuga tensho is a more augmented
version when he is using his
holification the power speed size and
blast Force are all dramatically
increased pretty much to the point where
it is extremely difficult to control as
it could injure anyone in the
surrounding area be them Friend or Foe
ichigo's enhanced speed has allowed him
to fire many getsuga tencho blasts all
at once from different directions
ukiora himself compared his getsuga tan
show to a hollow setup in particular
that of a cellularoscorus which is a
very creation of the Sero used by the
Espada in their release State now when
Ichigo combines both his Bankai and his
holification powers his getsuga tensho
is said to be his most ultimate attack
each go also has the ability to repair
parts of his mask that have been chipped
or damaged slightly but only if he has
enough Spirit power to do so we saw him
do this in his fights with both grimjao
and ukiora now the main problem Ichigo
had with his holification was the
duration of how long he could maintain
his masked form at first it was
literally only four seconds at a time
after the visor training he managed to
more than double this to 11 seconds
which doesn't sound like a lot but it
was often a small Gap that would turn
the tides of its Battles by his third
fight with gringel his time limit and
power for that matter had greatly
increased and each go could fight entire
battles while wearing the mask there was
no given reason as to how this was
achieved but as we know ichigo's growth
is second to none and I have you know
many time compared him to the Saiyans of
Dragon Ball So if you think about the
constant fights and setbacks he had
leading up to that third battle with
green jowl it makes perfect sense that
he was also growing in power with the
combat experience and you know in some
cases losses the time limit he had now
however is unknown but I'd imagine it is
tied into how much spirit Power Ichigo
has at the time now Ichigo also
displayed the ability to re-summon his
mask a second time after the time limit
had ended in the very early days of
learning to control this power it would
automatically smash upon its
re-summoning but later this ceases to be
an issue there's of course a little more
to talk about when it comes to ichigo's
hollow Powers but that will tie in when
we get to some of the key fights and
moments he has so we'll get into that as
we make our way forward now talking of
key fights we of course have to talk
about his fights with the Espada green
gel
green gel was an amazing character in
himself but he was also an amazing point
in ichigo's progression he was a sort of
Roadblock that Ichigo had to overcome to
not only get out of the funk that he was
in post-soul society but also in his
path to being able to control his new
Hollow Powers yes green gel was
basically a boss character in the story
at that point but the fights that he and
Ichigo had were more centered around
ichigo's progression in my opinion so
his first fight was a total disaster in
ichigo's point of view it technically
went down as a draw but each go
definitely took it as a loss greenjour
was just far too much for Ichigo at this
point as ichigo's attacks had zero
effect on him the only one that produced
any sort of damage was his black gets
Suga ten show but as the fight was
progressing ichigo's Focus shifted into
the fear that his inner Hollow was going
to take over him again luckily it was
kaname tozen forcing an enraged green
gel back to Waco Mundo that in ended
this fight before it got any worse
a month later Ichigo faced off against
greenjao again but this time with his
holification powers at this point Ichigo
had a time limit of 11 seconds that he
could stay in his Mass form which was
more than enough to completely overwhelm
the sixth rank to Sparta however it was
this time limit that determined the
outcome in this fight after the time
limit had exceeded greenjao was back on
top each go was pinned to the floor and
green Joe was about to finish Ichigo off
for good with a shadow only for rookia
to freeze his arm green Jazz attention
was then on her and as he tried to kill
her Shinji stepped in which forced
greenjour to retreat now their final
battle came in Waco Mundo where green
jowl is desperate to fight Ichigo at his
full power to which Ichigo obliges the
tide of this battle went back and forth
one moment Ichigo was on top the second
green gel had the advantage in this
fight Ichigo managed to keep his Hollow
Mask duration throughout the fight which
forced Greenhouse to use his
resurrection the battle continued to
rage on with both Fighters taking and
dishing out heavy damage greenjao is
about to deliver the Fatal blowers
Orihime yells out to Ichigo she begs for
him not to get hurt anymore which gives
Ichigo just the Boost that he needed in
doing so he managed to slash green gel
who went into a rage because of the
injury and used his strongest attack
discgorian which impaled ichigo's
stomach Ichigo managed to overcome the
attack and went on to deliver the final
blow in the fight and finally claim the
win this moves us on to ichigo's next
opponent and another one he had tussled
with on quite a few occasions through
that Last Arc that being the fourth
Espada ukiora where green jar was a
roadblock Ichigo had to overcome to
progress mentally and attain his hollow
Powers ukiora was the big test of
ichigo's power Not only was he the big
test of his power but there was also
some really big moments involving
ichigo's Hollow Powers not only that but
ukiora really Rose the bar here when it
came to the manner of opponents that
Ichigo had faced up to this point yes
each go had overcome some very strong
opponents by this point such as renji
kempachi biakya and recently greenjao
but ukiora took this to a new level he
was a terrifying power that completely
eclipsed anything we had faced before
and left us with the feeling that there
was literally no way for Ichigo to
overcome this ukiora delivered despair
to us as viewers their fight is again a
bit of a back and forth when ichco puts
on his Hollow Mask he gains the upper
hand against ukiora however when the
fight is moved to the top of lost noches
ukiora releases his zompoc toe Ichigo
does manage to survive the attacks but
he quickly comes to the realization that
ukiora is now much more stronger and
much more faster than he is now the two
have a conversation with battle that
again speaks to the power of ichigo's
resolve where ukiora asks each go why he
won't give up despite the huge
difference in the two's Powers Ichigo
replies by saying that nothing he sees
ukiora do will ever stop him from
fighting nor from giving up ukiora of
course is having none of it and his
answer only Sparks his desire to make
Ichigo feel deep despair ukiora
activates his resurrection and
completely controls The Battle Before
firing a Cerro blast that goes straight
through ichigo's chest which looks to be
game over for Ichigo orahime is on hand
to try and heal him and she pleads with
Ichigo to please help uriu fight ukiora
her words as always reach Ichigo and
this Sparks ichigo's transformation into
his new Hollow form known as the vasta
laude form the vasto laude form was
insane and this moment truly goes down
as one of the best ever here ichigo's
body is completely taken over by his
inner Hollow however this time it is a
full transformation physically and is
far more powerful than anything we had
ever seen not only that but the form
looked amazing as each go was pure white
in color with a smaller Hollow hole at
his chest with black markings that went
from that hole around to his shoulders
he also had claws on his fingertips and
Toes that were retractable around his
neck there were two red Tufts that also
appeared around his wrist his hair was
very long in this form reaching weight's
length and his Hollow mask was
completely different from what we had
ever seen it covered ichigo's entire
head and had black markings on it as
well as two demonic looking horns that
protruded from him in terms of power it
was just insane its strength was immense
this form moved an unimaginable speeds
his spirit Power which As We Know was
insane increased further and drastically
as well as that this form came with very
high speed regeneration and of course
with an enhanced Cerro a Cerro that was
abled completely overwhelm ukiora's
cello in the vasto laude form the battle
was over completely ukiora went from the
most terrifying thing we had ever seen
to being completely destroyed in a very
brutal manner by this new form Ichigo
was eventually returned to normal but he
was completely shocked by the absolute
devastation that he had just caused all
he could do in this moment was look on
as ukiora passed away so after this
fight each going Captain unahana
returned to the fake karakura town where
she heals and replenishes ichigo's
energy she explains the power of Eisen
shikai and tells Ichigo that he is now
the only one who can defeat him since he
is the only one who hasn't seen it thus
he won't be able to succumb to its
hypnosis power it's the only true
advantage the Soul Reapers had at this
point and one that they couldn't afford
to lose at any cost upon arriving Ichigo
attempts to cut down Eisen in one blow
but his strike is blocked by a barrier
Eisen tries to unnerve Ichigo with his
words but luckily komamura steps in just
as Ichigo was starting to lose himself
now all Ichigo can do here is wait for
an opening while the other Soul Reapers
take Eisen on he eventually finds one
after Eisen and Yamamoto have gone at it
and Strikes Eisen with a gets Suga
tencho unfortunately this isn't enough
as the hokyoku heals the wounds that
Eisen had suffered he does get a
compliment from Eisen in regards to his
spirit Power and how much he has grown
in power himself but tries to play the
Mind Games with Ichigo again saying that
his growth has all gone according to his
plans and that he had been watching each
ago from his very birth everything
Ichigo had done up to this point
including the battles he had had Eisen
claimed to have been and taken place
exactly as he wished luckily each goes
farther as Sheen steps in before
ichigo's anger boils over too much he
takes each girl away from eisen's
location explains the whole I'm a soul
Reaper thing sorry about keeping that a
secret before leaving back to eisen's
location where ichigo's next big test
begins in geen ichimaru now the fight
with geen is an interesting one
especially when we know what its true
purpose was in the fact that it was a
test from Gene to see if each go was
ready to defeat Eisen obviously Ichigo
is not ready at this point as geen is
the stronger of the two but there is
something Ichigo will still go on to do
now while in the dungai ishin instructs
ijigo that he must learn the final
getsuka tent show not only does he need
to learn this but he has to do it within
three months this is a technique that
the spirit of his zompoc toe will not be
pleased to hear him speak of ishine
continues to say that this is a
technique that their zompoc spirits will
be reluctant to teach them as each go
will find out why each girl goes on to
confront the true Spirit of his zonpok
toe this is the inner Hollow who has now
fused or merged with the other being
inhabiting the inner World representing
his Quincy Powers who of course refuses
to teach Ichigo this technique despite
ichigo's pleas that he must protect
karakura town at all costs the spirit
tells him that they are both protecting
different things so the two fights and
Ichigo figures out the technique and
more importantly the cost of the final
gezuka ten show which is that if he uses
this technique it will come at the cost
of his own soul Reaper Powers now the
final getsuga tensho works in the same
way as a normal guess Suga tent show
against sugatensho blast consumes some
of each Ghost spirit energy and
condenses that into an attack the final
Getsu potential is the same in that it
consumes each Ghost spirit energy and
uses it as an attack however it consumes
all of ichigo's spirit energy and thus
he will lose his soul Reaper powers for
good so Ichigo returns from the Don guy
in a new form it's not the final gets
Suga tensho form but what a lot of
people call dangai Ichigo here his hair
is longer and his clothing is also
slightly different his right hand is
covered in a black glove and the chain
from the hilt of his zompoc toe spirals
up to the length of ichigo's arm his
zombocto looks similar to that that it
did in his bonkai with some slight
changes mainly the cross guard it still
has the same shape as the Manji but the
prongs are much thinner here now
ichigo's presence when he arrives in
karakura town is nothing short of Epic
geen also acknowledges that Ichigo is
now ready to defeat Eisen because he now
has that look in his eyes the battle
with Eisen begins and each go destroys a
shocked and stunned Eisen for Ichigo he
knows that he must use the final gets
Suga tencho quickly as at this point
Eisen had become immortal and that he
was constantly evolving becoming
stronger and stronger himself that time
in the battle also quickly approached
and Ichigo active innovates the final
getsue attempt show in this form each go
just looks absolutely insane his hair
becomes jet black and grows in length to
waist length his body becomes covered in
a light bluish gray bandages covering
his torso right arm and his face just
beneath his eyes black flame markings
also appear from his chest and wrap
around his left arm here Ichigo is
constantly emitting black ryatsu with
the majority of it focusing around his
right arm you'll notice that he is not
wielding a sword in this form and that
is because he is now fused with zongetsu
itself the final gatsuga 10 show shakes
eyes and the absolute core he is in a
state of complete disbelief as he sees
that Ichigo has evolved to a plane
beyond that of a soul Reaper he
continues to question himself as he asks
if each go is now on a higher plane than
he himself is Ichigo then spreads his
right hand out and a black form of
spirit energy forms as each Ghost says
mugetsu mugetsu is translated as meaning
moonless sky and is the final attack a
blade of black spiritual energy is
generated in his hand that he then
swings at the Target remember this
attack is like a getsuga 10 show however
it draws all of each ghost spiritual
energy rather than just a portion of it
this creates a huge wall of black energy
to erupt heading straight towards its
Target the skies are blackened and
extreme damage is caused to any and
everything that is in its path even
still the energy will continue to rise
before it eventually disappears into the
sky now this move Doesn't Kill The
Immortal Eisen of course but severely
wounds and weakens him enough the
urahara can bind him with a very strong
keto spell the win goes to Ichigo but at
the cost of his soul Reaper Powers now
17 months after defeating Eisen Ichigo
is struggling to come to terms with the
loss of its power which comes during the
fall bring Arc we come across a method
called Full bring that will allow Ichigo
to regain his soul Reaper Powers Ichigo
was able to store spirit Power in an
item which in his case was his soul
Reaper badge this allowed each girl to
finally learn how to control Spirit
energy without leaking it like he always
had ichigo's attachment and emotions
tied with the badge and what it
represents to him from his pride in
being a soul Reaper allowed him to
awaken his full brain powers now
fullbring Powers allow one to bring out
the full potential of an item or piece
of equipment that they have a strong
Affinity with from his soul Reaper badge
Black Spirit energy emits from it that
form the shape of a super this first
stage of his full bring is mainly for
defense where he can block incoming
attacks coming his way later his
fullbring powers evolve further in that
they change his appearance and his
powers also evolve his whole body is now
covered in this black Spirit energy and
produce a Black Blade that forms over
his right arm his abilities here are
referred to as a clad type due to the
fact that Ichigo was covered in his own
power much like his bunker used to be
when his clothing represented how much
spiritual power that he have left once
his fullbring training was completed
ichigo's power transforms into a white
armor that covers his chest shoulders
arms and feet with a stripe that ran
across his face under this was a black
bodysuit in this form each Goku contain
turn his soul Reaper badge into a sword
of his own now through fullbring Ichigo
began to regain his soul Reaper Powers a
little bit at a time and once those
Powers return his full bring and saw
Reaper Powers will fuse together however
Ichigo is portrayed by ginjo who had
been helping each go learn the full
bring technique ginjo stole ichigo's
full bring and Ichigo pleaded for him to
give his powers back to him he wasn't
going to lose his powers again not after
he had worked so hard to get them back
now it is here where Rukia stabs Ichigo
in the back with a reishi blade that has
the spirit Power of several different
Soul Reapers the fact that ichiko can
now see Rukia here means that Ichigo had
now finally regained his soul Reaper
powers and he takes on a brand new form
those forbing Powers have indeed merged
with that of his soul Reaper Powers his
appearance is a mix between that of his
full bring armor and his sorry for
clothing the appearance of his shikai is
also different
the shape color and Hilt all look like
an upgraded and of course merged version
of that of his fullbring powers now the
fullbring arc is one that a lot of fans
didn't really get on board with or truly
understand I personally can see the
flaws in the arc but I also see what the
Arc was about it was progression for
Ichigo but not so much in a sense of
power but a huge mental development for
him and I really loved seeing that
progression in his character the reason
we spoke about it in this video is to
highlight that not only did Ichigo go
from losing his powers after using
mugetsu against eyes into regaining them
when stabbed by the reishi blade but he
went from nothing to more powerful than
he was so for me there is still
progression in his powers here too final
thing to mention on the full bring
Powers before we move on is the change
it also made on his bonkai look wise it
was amazing and similar to that of his
shikai in terms of you know it being a
clear mix or Fusion between that of what
we knew of his Bankai and the theme of
his 4 will bring Powers but the coolest
thing for me was was definitely that of
his sword his sword became more curved
and had three separate protrusions along
its blunt and close to the tip of the
sword the chain of tenza zangetsu also
became longer attaching to the hilt of
the blade and ichigo's glove
this takes us to the events of the
Thousand-Year blood War Arc Ichigo is
sent to the sole Society in order to
save it and confront Yuan who's of
course the big bad here like the biggest
bad we've had in Bleach crazy Ichigo
learns that it was him who had ordered
the destruction of the cerate and in his
anger goes on the offensive the
difference in power between these two is
far too great and you are completely
overwhelms and takes Ichigo down with
ease now we do see one of ichigo's
Quincy abilities on show here that he
had of course inherited from his
mother's side called Blitz fan which is
German for blood vein yuha goes to stab
Ichigo but he is saved by this ability
this ability there are two blurs and
this is the defensive one when Ichigo
was imprisoned by Opie it transferred
some of his riyatsu to each go that had
awakened the Quincy power that his
mother had left to him within that power
also lied memories giving him access to
this ability so this ability allowed him
to survive the stabbing attack from
yuhar leaving only a small cut compared
to the Fatal blow that it would have
been this power is also used to help
each go when he sustains critical wounds
he has taken and can stop the huge loss
of blood that the wound would have
caused of course we actually saw this
way back when in his first fight with
Kenpachi as the then zongetsu use this
ability to help stop the bleeding from
the wound that each go had suffered by
kempachi's blade so that he could fight
together with zangetsu to battle
campachi the battle with yuhar continues
and as he tries to leave Ichigo attempts
to prevent him however jugram cuts the
blade of his bonkai sword tenses and
Getsu clean in two leaving Ichigo
completely powerless each ghost survives
but learns through mayori that a broken
bunkai can never be fixed however the
royal guard arrive who take each go to
the soul King Power Alice in order for
his Bankai to be reforged after healing
and having his powers not only restored
and increased Ichigo and renji are sent
in Maya's place where the two are forced
to fight the asachi in order for them to
have their sambokto reforged after three
days each go had failed to defeat the
asachi and nimaya sends him back to the
human world where is Sheen reveals the
truth about his mother being a Quincy
and the circumstances around her death
with this truth Ichigo returns to
nemaya's place he watches the forging of
his new zombie and Ichigo learns the
truth about the beings in his inner
world he learns that the old man he
thought he knew of zongetsu wasn't
actually zongetsu but the being who
represented his Quincy powers in his
inner world as he searched for answers
he finds out that his inner Hollow is
actually his true zompoc toe the real
zongetso he had been mostly suppressing
all this time after this reveals on
Getsu allows Ichigo access to the full
power of his zombok toe and in the real
world each goes true zompoc toe is
forged so his shikai comes in the form
of two separate black swords one is the
size of his previous sword that we are
all very familiar with and the second
blade is like that of a knife so the
larger blade represents his inner Hollow
that we now know as the true zangetsu
and is his true zombie the smaller blade
represents the old man that Ichigo had
acknowledged as zangetsu all this time
and is the manifested spirit of ichigo's
Quincy Powers now ichigo's true shikai
powers are both energy attacks the first
is of course the getsuga 10 show we are
all familiar with each go can fire a
gets Suga tensho blast with both of his
swords with the smaller blade he simply
points it towards his Target and makes a
small slashing motion the bigger sword
is the more powerful of the two and when
used with this Blade the color of the
get Suga tensho attack is completely
black now each go also has the move
called getsuga jujisho which is
translated as meaning Moon Fang
cross-shaped piercer here he will fire
against sugar tensho with each of his
blades at the same time in a crossed
motion this fuses the two getsuga tensho
blasts into one insane attack now a lot
of course happens in the Thousand Year
blood War arc when it comes to the
question of ichigo's powers and how
strong is he but the big thing that we
should probably focus on in this Arc is
of course the final battle with yuha so
let's skip ahead to then so in his final
battle against yuhar Ichigo entered a
new Hollow form after learning the truth
about his powers and he had gained his
reforged zompoc Tome each goes Hollow
and Quincy Powers were in balance with
one another this balance can be
disrupted allowing Ichigo to merge with
his inner Hollow which causes a very
powerful transformation which we see
here in this fight this is ichigo's
merged Hollow form the left side of his
face and neck changed to look like that
of his vasto laude form when he fought
against ukiora that left eye becomes
black with the yellow Iris like when he
was using his holification powers he
also gains a singular white horn again
like that of the vasto Lorde form and
his sambok toe becomes pure white in
color this form completely skyrockets
ichigo's overall power in terms of his
speed strength and spiritual power now
the big boy attack in this form is his
combined Grand Ray Sarah gets Suga
tensho which is where he will use his
zongetsu blade as a second horn using
his own blood as a power supply Ichigo
is able to fire a grand Ray Sarah and
combine it with a getsue ten show this
created a blast so powerful that it was
enough to wound however this wound was
easily patterned down by him but he does
take Ichigo a lot more seriously from
now on the battle between these two is
amazing and yuha is literally on another
level however with the help of Eisen of
all people who tricks yuhar using the
power of kyokosoi gets you into thinking
he had defeated both Ichigo and renji
the non-alusian aka the real Ichigo is
bought just enough time to get behind
yuha and cuts him clean in half with a
very powerful golden gatsuga ten show
blast thus he defeats this incredibly
powerful opponent the most powerful
opponent we have seen in all of bleach
now the final thing to talk about with
ichigo's power and abilities is his
bonkai now he has his truths on poktoe
to activate his bunkai Ichigo places the
two blades of his shikai together
creating a surge of energy around him
and the swords now the power of ichigo's
true tenza zengetsu is currently unknown
but we do know that he is considered
extremely dangerous
we also know that he can fire and
enhance getsue a 10 show this is much
more powerful than a normal one and is
also golden color the one that finished
off yuha but unfortunately that is all
we know for now
so just how strong is Ichigo well that's
an answer we don't really have as of yet
is the fact he is still getting stronger
and stronger there seems to be
absolutely no limit to what he can
achieve and just when you think that he
is at the peak of his powers he will
find a new way to surpass that we
obviously know that he is without a
doubt not only one of the strongest
characters in the series but also one of
the strongest characters in all of anime
so I hope this video allowed you to
understand just how strong he is by
pointing out these key points in his
story and by highlighting his powers and
abilities this was easily one beast mode
of a video to make so if you've made it
this far big props to you and thanks it
truly means a lot let us know in the
comment section below what your favorite
Power of each goes is and which of his
fights you enjoyed the most now if you
enjoyed this video and you'd like to see
more bleach videos on the channel make
sure to let us know by Smashing that
like button if you haven't already make
this the video you subscribe and hit
that notification Bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
anime abroad videos whilst you wait for
more bleach videos to drop on the
channel make sure to check out our ever
growing bleach playlist that includes
videos on all Bankai or shikai the
captains ranked weakest to strongest and
much more link to that is in the video
description below until next time my
friends take care of yourselves peace